nick viall hi it's nice to meet you nice
to meet you your hair is curly it's
styled
it's curly yeah how much how much time
did that take you today you think
15 seconds wow
yeah you're killing it in life well i
used to spend a lot of time on my hair
yeah and then i realized it looks
exactly the same whether it's been 15
seconds
or 12 minutes on it
yeah like that comes with maturity which
yes grown madness yeah okay so
the bachelor has been on television for
20 years how do you think it's changed
television and also just the culture
well i don't know if it's changed
television all too much because the the
show hasn't changed a ton
i think
i think it's made the reality tv dating
landscape more
competitive i mean for a long time i
think a lot of
a lot of people try to make
dating shows that people watched with
little luck and i think recently you
know you've seen
it have some competition and so i think
maybe in a good way i'm a big believer
in competition i think it's good i think
i think that has put pressure on the
bachelor franchise to maybe
uh
make some tweaks you know you have two
bachelorettes this season i think that's
a positive thing and change is good you
know
for the longest time they haven't really
had to have
much much change for their shows it's
kind of been the same
same stuff over and over and it's still
a great show but
culture wise um
i think
you know i don't know how much the
bachelor has it i think culture has had
more of an impact on the show rather
than the show having an impact on
culture okay uh you know with reality tv
dating shows um just in general i think
you know with the internet has bringing
a heightened awareness to everything
yeah and and especially with things that
people find frustrations with
i think dating is definitely one of
those
things that people find frustrating and
um and so now you have
a heightened sense of
of expectations i think with when it
comes to dating especially with you know
the bachelor audience which
both men and women enjoy but i think
it's a predominantly a woman audience
and
you have an audience of women who have
heightened expectations of what they
expect from men in dating and i think
that we've all become
you know a little more educated in terms
of
uh more enlightened and what our
expectations should be with dating i
think dating in general has evolved um
people are settling down later in life
and through that i think the audience
now watches the show differently yeah
and with that i think it has
challenged shows to
become more progressive and and maybe um
adjust their shows accordingly okay
if that makes sense yeah
yeah
that's gonna be a three minute tick tock
okay yeah
just try
so you've been on the bachelor the
bachelorette bachelor in paradise i have
yeah which one's your favorite oh
paradise for sure yeah yeah paradise is
well because it's the most normal in a
very non
normal environment yeah that's you have
multiple women and multiple men it's a
place you can have friendships in with
both genders you don't have a fixated
focus on one person you know um
the bachelorette or the bachelorette you
know you have a singular
lead unless you have two leads but even
then and
in a very controlled environment and i
think that is it's deliberately meant to
elicit
emotions and you can start falling for
kind of anyone and you when you um
when you
when you
narrow your focus and limit your options
it's it's easy to
start eliciting emotions and so paradise
it's
there's
more friendships there's more community
and again
you can
be kind of more authentic with who
you're you're dating because you have
options you have options which one would
you never go on again
all of them i would never call on any of
them again i think you know again
i appreciate my experiences but my time
has passed but the experience of
paradise if i could
you know do that with some of my closest
friends and go back and relive that
without the dating part since i i'm in a
happy relationship
it was that part of like summer camp was
yeah was a fun kind of
spending time with friends on a beach
who doesn't have fun doing that yeah if
you weren't in a happy relationship and
you were still single would you go back
on one of those shows no no you're just
over i've i've i had been single for a
while before i met natalie and yeah i
was
um i mean i i've i've done everything
there is to do literally on on that show
there's not there's nothing else left to
do yeah do you have a favorite reality
show
um not the bachelor i guess in terms of
far as far as rally show it's it's an
entertaining show i obviously it's near
and dear to my heart i've enjoyed some
of these newer ones like love is blind
and the ultimatum i've enjoyed those and
um
but yeah
yeah when you're watching reality tv
since you've done so many of them right
when you're watching reality tv
can you tell what scripted and what's
genuine reality
do you get like that feeling of yeah no
i definitely i i i'm guessing i watch it
differently yes um
than that so the average viewer yeah um
i'm always mindful of the soundtrack
they're playing
um
because that really
changes your perspective on any given
moment or situation
um because if you listen to the music
you can
it'll tell you what the show wants you
to feel
regardless of how you might actually
feel yeah um so if it's a happy music
they want you to feel happy if it's
suspenseful music or villainous music
they want you to
think um that way as well yeah uh also
if
if you see people walking and um you
hear them talking but you don't see them
talking you know those are things i just
pay attention to to
try to have an informed and objective
opinion about someone and it's very
subtle you have to watch very closely to
notice it yeah so a lot of uh bachelor
nation stars
have podcasts
what makes yours unique and how did it
come about like first of all it looks
amazing in here so uh yeah i was lucky
to have a good team around me yeah um
i when i first started my podcast um
i wanted it to be
um something that was
something i was passionate about and i
wanted it to be
um you know thought of as more than
another bachelor podcast um and
depending on who listens i for i have
three different formats right and and
like you know and then so some people
might still see it as one but
when
the show started we didn't spend a lot
of time talking about the bachelor we
would here and there and we'd have
some bachelor guests on but it was
more about relationships in dating and
social dynamics and it was an
opportunity for me to learn as well i've
it's been really cool to have
a variety of guests that i get to meet
whether it's a celebrity or an expert
and i just like talking about things
that were i find interesting um
and
being someone from bachelor nation and
and from you know i i
my platform being on the bachelor has
given me an audience of a lot of women
and it's something i'm appreciative and
and don't take for granted
but as a someone who was going to be a
male host i wanted to
use that opportunity to be someone who
you know i could learn from my audience
and maybe they could learn from me as
well to have a lot of conversations
especially around dating and
relationships because
that's
i'm i've always been someone that i i've
i've always grown as an individual by
talking to people who
aren't like me
uh well you know all different walks of
life and regardless of the context and
and so
i like having conversations with people
who
uh i don't always relate to and so you
know talking about dating relationships
um
you know i think it's it's easy for men
to want to talk to men and easy for
women to want to talk to women about
their experiences but i wanted to create
an environment where um we could all
learn from each other you know or were
me as a man you know are talking about
my experiences and my point of view but
also you know i i primarily have women
guests not always but uh i wanted to
create a you know just kind of a place
of conversation so um that people who
are struggling with relationships and
dating and feel frustration could come
and feel a little bit more hopeful about
their experiences and a little more
optimistic and
if they're struggling with something
maybe my show or something we're talking
about them you know something we're
talking about uh makes them feel a
little less
helpless yeah because dating can be very
discouraging and helpless sometimes do
you have anyone on your dream guest list
uh harry styles
yeah number one oh two people with good
hair
the ladies would love to see it harry
has great hair i i'm just thankful i
have have hair um
well i i've recently become a harry
styles stan i saw him at coachella and
he took my breath away like most people
um but he's a really empathetic
you know he i've
i think they take away when i saw him is
that um
obviously he has an audience of of women
as well um
and
you you saw how he connected with his
audience through his music and just as a
performer and i was just really
impressed by that um and i also have an
audience of of women and
um a little smaller scale but um one of
my shows is to
hear
you know people's stories many of them
are women to talk about their struggles
and
like justin long i think i think harry
would thrive being a very empathetic
person to give words of encouragement
to people who are struggling i think
harry would enjoy it also i'm
convinced that harry and i
uh had a moment uh he was i was running
he was driving and
um he had he stopped and we stared at
each other as i kept running and then i
was like i think that's harry styles and
i've recently seen a photograph of
him in a car which was the same car it
was definitely hairy okay i dm'd him
he didn't respond how long was the eye
lock like where are we at with it was it
three well it felt like forever but in
reality it was
a split second but he
if it was him
he looked at me he looked he looked at
me like he knew me
i've heard he's a bachelor fan
oh
we've already seen it
so
i don't know were you in your best were
you having a good moment i was running
with my shirt off so i was
oh
so it was giving me a watch where were
you why were you crossing the street
with your shirt off i was running you
don't oh you were running
and i also think harry runs so maybe he
was just appreciating my gate
you know yeah i don't know it might not
i'm not 100 certain it was him but i i'm
95 certain it was him so you slid in his
dms what did you say like what was like
did you say hey i saw you with my shirt
i said good luck any chance that was
you um
that i saw while i was running and um
crickets i'm a big fan and uh
that's it that's it
i just kept it short and sweet